anyone know the russian term for get
hyped from dark symbolism to a
mysterious portable cryo chamber here's
everything you missed in the secret
invasion trailer drips of information
about the upcoming marvel series secret
invasion have found their way to the
public via both news outlets and other
mcu films since it was first announced
by disney in december of 2020 samuel
jackson and kobe smalders will star as
nick fury and maria hill in their third
mcu series together on top of his nine
and her six appearances in the film
universe yeah well
this is different
we also have been long aware that ben
mendelsohn will make his third showing
in the marvel universe has the skrull
talos in the spider-man far from home
post-credits scene it's revealed that
fury and hill were actually talos and
fellow skrull soren throughout the
events of that film they call the real
fury who is seen sunning himself on a
virtual reality beach from the safety of
a skrull ship he jumps to his feet to
look for his shoes declaring himself
ready for action and presumably kicking
off the events of secret invasion disney
plus just released the first teaser
courtesy of d23 and while it's less than
two minutes long it does provide some
additional clues as to what the series
has in store in one brief sequence
taylor's questions kingsley benadir's
unknown character in a casual dining
hall surrounded by diners and a handful
of floor-to-ceiling portraits of several
historical figures all tagged as the
faces of freedom as talus moves to
threaten benadir the innocuous looking
crowd all morphs into copies of the
villain and stands ominously around
taylor's the action takes place in the
national gallery of london and at least
some of the photos in the background are
indeed real over on the left you can see
winston churchill that is from a real
painting done by sir william orpin in
1916. it certainly is painting the
appearance no pun intended that the
skrulls have been present throughout
history and perhaps some of the most
famous faces of freedom were actually
skrulls
okay the pun was intended there
in one very brief sequence fury rests on
a leaf-covered brick patio with one foot
propped up on a dingy fountain base or a
bird bath looking up at a raven perched
in a tree above him fury looks like he's
stopping to catch his breath and raven
appearing overhead can't make him feel
any better about whomever or whatever is
chasing him ravens are most commonly
associated with either impending doom or
a tragedy in the near past but according
to world birds raven symbolism is also
tied to shapeshifters and they are
thought to be spell casters the raven
could be signaling to fury that
something terrible is either just about
to happen or has just gone down or it
could be a skrull hovering there over
fury and watching him whether the bird
appears to provide assistance or
surveillance is also not yet completely
clear although fury does at least appear
to be allied with talos throughout the
entire trailer so he presumably has at
least a few scroll buddies on his side
we gotta be very careful now
it's not entirely clear where secret
invasion will take place but sharp eyes
will no doubt catch a couple of clues
pointing to a few russian locations on
the door of a bar where fury meets hill
for the first time in many years hangs a
printout of a sign with russian wording
on it that translates roughly to thank
you for not smoking later there's an
explosion in moscow's red square next to
a lamppost banner with the russian word
for native above another partially
legible word in the most ominous
appearance of russian text an
unidentifiable agent that could be hill
opens the door to a large round room
where workers are welding together some
sort of giant framework over a raised
platform the lettering for the middle
word on the frosted glass isn't quite
readable but the other two words
translate to outside and prohibited near
the very end of the trailer we see a
long motorcade of black government
limousines and an armored car with
police escorts at the front and rear the
camera then jumps back to show a
helicopter and two missiles headed right
for the caravan one of the missiles hits
its target and the suv is launched into
the air to the horror of the stunned
driver we don't know for sure who the
vip is who warrants all this attention
both protective and antagonistic but in
typical marvel fashion government
agencies appear to play a big role in
secret invasion aside from whomever
rides in the mystery motorcade don
cheadle is back as james rhodes of the
us air force and is shown surrounded by
the standard assortment of military men
including a couple of military police
officers we also see two officers from
the department of damage control
carefully approach and open what looks
like a portable cryogenic chamber like
in pretty much every other segment of
the teaser trailer the scene jumps to
another one before we get any real idea
what is happening but this first
tantalizing look at secret invasion will
certainly spark plenty of anticipation
ahead of the spring 2023 release
[Music]